[Music]
hi Vanessa here I'm a marketer here at
Google for Google cloud platform and hi
for me
Alexander I'm on the Google cloud sales
team on this episode we'll look at cloud
BigTable the same database that powers
many of Google's core services including
search analytics maps and Gmail we'll
also run through a quick demo of the
self-paced lab where we'll use a
command-line utility to connect to cloud
BigTable instance and read and write
data in a table don't forget you can
also apply what you've learned here
today with a 300-dollar free trial
credit to use on GCP so let's get
started so let's look at some of the key
features of BigTable because big table
offers high performance under high load
large apps and workflows are faster more
reliable and more efficient running on
BigTable BigTable is ideal for storing
large amounts of data with very low
latency databases can automatically and
seamlessly scale to billions of rows and
thousands of columns allowing you to
store petabytes of data plus you only
pay for the amount of storage you use
because BigTable is a fully managed
service you don't need to worry about
configuring and tuning your database for
performance or scalability will also
create backups of your data to protect
against catastrophic events and allow
for disaster recovery big tables offered
through the same open source industry
standard API as HBase the native
database by the Apache Hadoop project
the HBase compatible interface provided
by BigTable supports the movement of
applications between HBase and BigTable
as big table is part of the GCP
ecosystem it can interact with other
services and third-party clients in
terms of security all data in BigTable
is encrypted both in flight and at rest
while access to BigTable data is easily
controlled through iam permissions
[Applause]
this hands-on lab you'll use the CBT
command-line utility to connect to a
cloud BigTable instance and read and
write data in a table you can check out
the link to start the quick lab here you
will need to set aside about 30 minutes
to complete it so far in the lab we've
created a cloud BigTable instance and
configured CBT to use your project and
instance by modifying the dot CBT RC
file
we create a table called my
- table we list the tables to verify my
- table was created we add a column
family named CF one we list the column
families to verify CF one was created we
put the value test - value in row R 1
using the column family CF 1 and the
column qualifier C 1 we read the data
add it to the table we hope you enjoyed
this episode please feel free to share
your experiences or ideas of using
BigTable it's always good to hear from
you if you haven't already done so check
out this link where you can apply what
you've learned using a three hundred
dollar free trial credit on Google cloud
platform all of our additional training
resources are linked below thanks again
for watching and see you soon